well you controlled by money right so
like like let's say the baby in his
situation right
he's only losing because he allowed them
to control how much money he's making
he allowed them to say you're gonna book
me on these festivals until we decide
that this is our culture and we are
controlling it and we can do our own
thing we empower them lame ass festivals
facts we empower those yuppy ass events
we imp we're the reason that you exist
it's some kind of confusion that we need
you it's some kind of confusion that
rolling live we didn't make that [ __ ] we
made that [ __ ]
you take us off of that [ __ ] that [ __ ]
is nothing but a [ __ ] reject version
of [ __ ] woodstock right
so again until we understand the power
in our culture that this hip-hop [ __ ] is
well guess what every time we try to go
to mainstream america anytime they feel
like they want to they can just slap us
down and be like [ __ ] you [ __ ] get down
bam but if we decided to take it into
our own hands and control it then we
could say what we want to we can control
our own message right now we we at the
control of the dollar